and and that's the thing like like
you said i was all pointed to crap how
do you be optimistic though terrible
it's like how about you but i'm hanging
off that last minute when it's great
yeah
a hollywood favorite for decades after
michael j fox went public with his
parkinson's disease diagnosis in 1998
the actor continued to win the hearts of
television viewers in shows like the
good wife boston legal and the michael j
fox show now during a recent appearance
on mike for big leah's podcast working
it out the actor is opening up about his
decision not to take roles with a lot of
lines due to his inability to memorize
dialogue i don't take on something with
a lot of lines i can't do it i can't
and in whatever reason oh it's i can't
do the person it's just what it is i
can't remember five minutes i can't do
it can't be done yeah so i go to the
beach when i did
i used to go spin off from
good wife which is a
good good uh good fight good fight um
that was what i wanted to say i couldn't
remember once
and i just had this blunt but i couldn't
remember the lines oh and it was strange
because it was family times they used to
give me the script i go
my man now we got off the phone
and then wow he knew it like it was
instant and and it continued to be away
from me although fox reportedly retired
from acting in 2020 the canadian
detailed how he rethought his decision
after watching a scene from quentin
tarantino's once upon a time in
hollywood saying
scroll back but he was doing a scene in
the western show and he can remember his
lines he went back in the dress room he
was screaming himself he was like
you know
he's just tearing into himself in the
mirror and like drinking in in and
it's just a mess
and i thought about that i thought i
don't want to do that so i don't
my am i am i wrong not to feel that my
my right yeah
now since his diagnosis fox has been an
absolutely huge advocate for parkinson's
and other neurological diseases founding
the michael j fox foundation in 2000 and
raising over 1 billion for research
despite all of that the actor says he
does not think there will be a cure for
the disease in his lifetime i'm really
blunt with people about cures when they
ask me if i will be relieved of
parkinson's in my lifetime i say i'm 60
years old and science is hard so no i am
genuinely a happy guy adding i don't
have a morbid thought in my head i don't
fear death at all